before we get to that though man i want
to go to doc's old team
his old team and the celtics which i
know that's the finals matchup you want
you want to see
doc against boston and brad stevens in
the finals i know that's what you're
rooting for
that's good oh that's good game one
heat celtics i need you to put aside
your boston loyalty
you know and uh and and give me your
objective
first you're a reporter i know i know i
know you're objective no no no i'm not
no
all these are important objectivity
doesn't exist it does not exist
nobody's objective no no no no yes no
i'll tell you who's objecting i mean i
mean you're working on the celtics book
right now
i know robots your next new york times
seller i know i think you got a lot of
different things
i just got notice on it i just got
noticed on it right now yeah
i saw that you got a vested interest i
know you got you you ain't exactly got
money on it but you know you got you're
you're invested i'm in this but just
what's going to happen in this series
we'll always keep it 100 with you right
we'll always keep 100 i'm not writing
about this celtics team i'm writing
about a team from another era
okay another don't act like it don't
help don't act like it don't help it all
helps
it all helps that's true every little
bit helps but anyway
what do you expect oh just aside man
what do you expect going into this my
hey mama needs a new kitchen that's what
i'm saying that's that's
it keep the money coming all right so uh
really
i think i think the celtics are i think
the celtics are the more talented team
but what does that mean they're talented
but they haven't done they haven't
proven
anything see both of these teams are in
the same position
like jimmy butler's never been to the
finals
jayson tatum and jaylen brown had never
been to the finals like if you look at
if you look at the rosters you can't
really make a determination on that
the only guy who's got finals experience
is a head coach
and and eric spoelstra and brad stevens
i think that's about a wash i know
spoelstra's got two titles but he also
had lebron and d-wade on his side so
uh i i think this is going to be a a
seven-game
series now you don't think i'm saying
anything controversial
people in boston are saying this is
going to be five celtics and five
celtics and are you serious yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah this is a tough series man i
mean i got something surprised i mean of
course they do
i'm sure i'll tell you the key to the
series
i was talking about i was giving jimmy
butler a lot of love yesterday jimmy
butler is not the key to the series
bam bam bam out of value
i'll tell you why the celtics
they're weak in the middle and he has
destroyed them
all season long so if they don't have
answers for them
yeah it's a seven game series that miami
wins so it might be
uh heat versus lakers lebron
hello say hello to your past uh in the
nba finals
so yeah no i like the seven game series
call which is another way of saying
i have no idea how this is really going
to go i just got to play out it's like
it's
that it's that close there's a lot to
like about both teams and i feel you
it's like making a prediction
about this is is really really difficult
because
i mean the the heat are not just this
cute story
you know that's pulled off some upsets
like i mean they're they're a legit
contender um and you know what kind of
damage they do from the
three-point line but conversely as you
know boston's really good at defending
the three-point line
right which is why and this is going to
frustrate you dude so i just want you to
be ready
i'm expecting that angry edgy michael
holly because
on one hand it's gonna be a classic
close series that i i agree goes seven
games
it's gonna come down to the foul line
dude and your entire
you know this this theory that you come
up with that bubble basketball
and we've talked about this off camera
that bubble basketball
is uh better in that
it removes any kind of home-court
advantage vis-a-vis
officiating is going to literally be put
to the tests
right because you're talking about a
team in miami
that parades to the foul line and as you
know a team in boston that struggles to
defend without fouling
and so this is it it might be a free
throw shooting contest is what i'm i'm
telling you to get ready to sign up for
that okay that's fine it might be
like and i'm just it's the last thing
i'll say because we got to talk to benny
goodwill man we got to talk to
goodwill is going to be in the house in
a second look
bubble basketball is not great but
without bubble basketball
guess who wouldn't be in the conference
finals
the miami heat nor the celtics oh oh
because yeah yeah
you you think you think they would have
won the first two games in milwaukee
like they won the first two games in a
bubble both teams both teams did that
celtics were about to go up 3-0 until a
dude who's four foot ten
threw the basketball over a dude who's
ten feet tall seven
twelve seven twelve yeah that means no
ten feet all right
how do you how do you complete that but
anyway that's because of the bubble
so you can hate on it if you want but
you wouldn't have this match up
if you didn't have lake lake buena vista
florida
you